if you look to Republican primary
debates for serious policy discussion on
immigration you're not gonna find it
instead you'll find this mr. Trump you
have called for deporting every
undocumented immigrant Donald Trump's
plan his plan his big wall your plan
Donald Trump's plan to immediately
deport 11 to 12 million undocumented
immigrants Donald Trump has dragged the
immigration debate way to the right
instead of constructive policy ideas the
candidates were forced to respond to why
they all believe it's not a good idea to
up and deport 11 million people truth be
told the Republican presidential
hopefuls actually have real things to
say on what to do with undocumented
immigrants Senator Marco Rubio was
actually one of the fiercest proponents
of a comprehensive immigration bill back
in 2013 which included a path to
citizenship since the bills failure he's
backed away from that support and like
most Republican candidates he's now
hammering on border security even though
the US has doubled the number of Border
Patrol agents in the past decade and
illegal immigration numbers have
actually dropped since 2007 two
governors in the running Mike Huckabee
and chris Christie actually supported
legislation in their states that gave
in-state college tuition rates to
undocumented students how could be
recently defended this support saying
you don't punish a child for something
his parents did but Christie who also
once supported a path to citizenship has
changed his tune since running for
president he's been a little more Trumpy
he's actually suggested tracking
immigrants who overstay their visas like
FedEx packages here's what we need to do
we need to use electronics great idea we
can call it immigrant Prime another
governor Scott Walker supported a path
to citizenship to as recent as 2013 now
during primaries he's drastically rolled
back his views and says he shares
opinions quote very similar to Trump Jeb
Bush has said he would support a path to
citizenship as part of a larger
immigration package he once said of
undocumented immigrants that yes they
broke the law but
it's an act of love it's an act of
commitment to your family meanwhile
Hillary Clinton tweeted during the
debate hard-working law-abiding
immigrant families deserve a path to
earn citizenship not second-class status
both she and Bernie Sanders support a
path to citizenship and expanding Barack
Obama's immigration reforms and here's
the kicker since the loss in 2012 the
Republican National Committee has worn
their party in a report we must embrace
and champion comprehensive immigration
reform if we do not our party's appeal
will continue to shrink so will the GOP
stop following Trump's lead and actually
talk policy the 2016 presidential
election is the most expensive yet we
said no wrong I went to number one and
you went down the tubes